I know Al isn't here he's still healing  and recovering as Mr Roku would say yes  best time of the day all right no  mention if the Beloved weather anchor is  still hospitalized after being  readmitted for blood clots in his leg  and lungs but today Al seemingly hinted  he'd spend the holidays at home posting  his daughter's cooking videos and  requesting Christmas morning breakfast  [Music]  with those cutouts the show found a way  for the 68 year old to make their  holiday card Val's been off the air for  five weeks today his wife ABC news  reporter Deborah Roberts posted our  hearts are warmed by the love thoughts  and prayers our family has lifted and  forever grateful for the unceasing  beauty of support from near and far he  is watching us this morning providing  real-time feedback  no no yes I'm sure he will now  foreign  [Music]